Buonasera a tutti e grazie mille per
l'introduzione per l'invito
oggi cercherò di parlarvi delle mie due
passioni in ambito professionale che
sono la robotica e neuroscienze Come
state introdotte detto così a qualcuno
potrebbe venire il dubbio Cosa hanno in
comune qualcosa si può intravedere in
realtà Spero che alla fine del mio
discorso saremo tutti d'accordo che
hanno molte cose in comune per farlo vi
devo un po' così spiegare cosa sono la
lobodire neuroscienze può sembrare
intuitivo
Immagino che tutti voi quando sentite
parlare di robot
immaginate un sistema di questo tipo un
robot antropomorfo cioè che ha la forma
e cerca di replicare le funzioni
dell'uomo in realtà i robot antropomorfi
sono una piccola parte della robotica
che si chiama robotica umanoide mentre
invece la robotica si occupa di
tantissime altre cose Dai robot per
pulire la casa che abbiamo in alcune
delle nostre case e i robot industriali
ai robot che si usano per la in ambito
medico per la chirurgia o per la
riabilitazione cosa hanno queste
macchine in comune per definire il
settore della robotica prendo a
riferimento delle parole del professor
Michael brediche e il professore che ha
fondato a metà degli anni 80 i robotics
Lab di Oxford che tradotto in italiano
suonano come la robotica e quel settore
della Conoscenza scientifica e
tecnologica che ha l'obiettivo di
trasformare le informazioni
del della percezione quindi le
informazioni che vengono dai sensori in
un'azione cioè la differenza tra un
robot e un qualsiasi dispositivo
elettronico che potete avere in tasca e
che il robot si muove nel mondo fisico e
interagisce col mondo può scambiare
forze col mondo esterno ma di fatto la
robotica si occupa di controllare il
movimento in maniera intelligente di
queste macchine date le informazioni che
vengono dai sensori che a bordo
e di cosa si occupano le neuroscienze
questo forse un pochino più intuitivo
l'errosciante si occupano del cervello
non solo del cervello umano ma
tendenzialmente il cervello e il
cervello è questo sistema straordinario
che ha fino a 100 miliardi di neuroni e
fino a un milione di miliardi di
connessioni È difficile un numero
complicato da immaginare anche per me
che lavori in quest'ambito ho cercato
ieri Quant'è il PIL mondiale espresso in
dollari il film mondiale è espresso in
dollari È circa un poco meno di 100.000
miliardi Ecco il numero di connessioni
numericamente che abbiamo dentro di noi
il cervello di ognuno di noi è 10 volte
numericamente maggiore del PIL mondiale
espresso in dollari
domanda Secondo voi questo sistema A
cosa serve Qual è la funzione principale
del cervello non so se qualcuno vuole
azzardare una risposta la prima cosa che
mi verrebbe da dire a me non conoscendo
l'ambito è serve a pensare a sognare e
immaginare A non tutte quelle funzioni
che noi immaginiamo possa il nostro
cervello
stare lì per per svolgere in realtà è
abbastanza assodato che il controllo del
movimento non è solo una delle tante
funzioni del cervello Ma è probabilmente
il motivo per cui il cervello esiste vi
faccio un esempio con questa essere
Marino che è un essere Marino della
famiglia dei tunicati che quando è nella
sua fase infantile
per nutrirsi ha bisogno di muoversi e
quindi ha una struttura
nervosa di circa 300 cellule quando
invece cresce mette radici può nutrirsi
dal suolo Siccome non ha più necessità
di muoversi riassorbe il cervello lo
mangia e Lo digerisce non ha più bisogno
di muoversi smette di avere un cervello
per cui detto semplificando al massimo
la robotica si occupa di gestire e
controllare il movimento di un corpo
artificiale il cervello si occupa di
umano o animale
Chi è più bravo dei due lascia giudicare
a voi questo è un robot commerciale il
robot Secondo me nel controllo del
Movimento più avanzato che esista al
mondo si chiama Atlas di una società di
Boston dynamics che
fa delle cose per me che sono robotico
incredibile Quando ho iniziato a fare
questa questo mestiere circa vent'anni
fa i robot a manoppera riuscivano a fare
qualche passo senza cadere Ok adesso
questo robozza alta fa capriole quanto è
bravo l'uomo a fare le stesse cose
Questo è un esempio di ragazzi
sicuramente ben allenati non come me
Diciamo che sono appassionati di parkour
si chiama questo sport non ho scelto un
atleta particolare di punta sono
migliaia di ragazzi che solo perché sia
No solo perché si allenano in maniera
intensa a farlo però riescono a fare
delle cose che nessun robot al mondo
potrebbe mai immaginare di far fare un
robot Ok la cosa più stupefacente di
tutti è che se andiamo a vedere le
caratteristiche dei due sistemi noi
abbiamo dei muscoli che sono 100 volte
più lenti dei motori che utilizziamo nei
robot abbiamo una velocità di
trasmissione dei nostri segnali che fino
a un milione di volte più lenta di
quella che abbiamo nei sistemi
artificiali è un ritardo nel controllo
dei movimenti che è circa 100 volte
maggiore per cui da qui viene lo stupore
è la necessità di
me ma di tantissime centinaia di persone
che fanno ricerca in questo ambito di
cercare di mettere insieme la disciplina
della robotica Occorre tenere la scienza
per capire meglio come il cervello lo fa
e poter
implementarlo in sistemi artificiali
Ora io di questa ambito che ho
introdotto vi parlerò di un caso
specifico non perché è più importante
degli altri o più rilevante ma
semplicemente perché è una cosa di cui
mi si è occupato negli ultimi tre anni
quindi la conosco un po' meglio delle
altre ed è questo progetto europeo che
ho la fortuna di coordinare che si
chiama combox e l'acronimo l'acronimo
inglese Che vuol dire
connessi tramite i robot l'idea è che
noi possiamo utilizzare delle interfacce
robotiche per mettere in connessione
fisica due persone per esempio un
maestro di violino è un discente di
violino oppure un bambino che sta
imparando a scrivere è il maestro o il
genitore e questa connessione che questi
robot fanno quindi una persona
interagisce con un robot l'altra persona
con un altro robot e i due sono connessi
tra di loro tramite un programma che
permette di passare forza e spostamenti
da una persona all'altra
questa cosa abbiamo proposto che possa
facilitare l'apprendimento di questi
Task molto difficili questi compiti È
molto difficili da dove ci viene l'idea
Beh l'idea è ancora ci viene dalle
neuroscienze motorie che hanno negli
ultimi anni studiato come il cervello
umano gestisce Questa interazione tra
uomini per esempio nella danza quando
bisogna spostare un oggetto
ora questi compiti sono abbastanza
complicati per cui quello che si fa
normalmente è che in ambito di ricerca
si semplifica Al massimo cercando di
mantenere le stesse caratteristiche del
compito per cui qualche anno fa un mio
collega dell'impire al college ha fatto
una serie di esperimenti in cui si
chiede a due persone di inseguire un un
target su uno schermo e le due persone
possono essere o connesse o non connesse
sempre tramite l'uso del robot quello
che ha visto è che
sia che sia più bravo sia che sia meno
Bravo quando lavora in coppia di fatto
miglioro questo grafico dice che sopra
lo zero il lavoro in coppia ha delle
performance maggiori che il lavoro da
solo Cioè lo stesso Task da solo quindi
è una sorta di strategia in cui sia Chi
è più bravo sia Chi è meno Bravo vince
sempre
nel nostro ambito di applicazione però
dove c'hai una persona molto brava a
fare un Task come un maestro una persona
che sta iniziando a fare quello stesso
Task Ci siamo chiesti se questo
meccanismo funzionasse lo stesso Allora
abbiamo fatto un'altra serie di
esperimenti in questo progetto che con
un compito un po' più complesso quindi
un movimento anche contro diciamo la
gravità sul piano che ci verticale per
cui è una rotazione di quel joystick
queste persone tengono in mano e a una
delle due abbiamo dato un Task più
difficile un compito più difficile cioè
il target anziché era essere ben
definito era molto più sfocato e più
difficile da inseguire proprio per
stimolare la condizione in cui c'è una
persona molto esperta è una persona meno
esperta l'altra idea che abbiamo avuto è
che siccome c'è questa relazione
asimmetrica nelle competenze delle due
persone forse l'aiuto dei robot valeva
la pena di valutare se funziona meglio
una connessione asimmetrica anche nello
scambio delle forze per cui abbiamo
pensato che la persona
meno brava a fare quel compito potesse
sentire una forza maggiore rispetto a
quella più brava che potesse sentire una
forza minore ovviamente l'abbiamo
sperimentato con tutti come si fa in
laboratorio con tutti i controlli del
caso cioè provando tutti i vari tipi di
interazione quello che abbiamo visto
ancora è che se si usa la strategia per
cui si le due persone si mettono in
comunicazione in maniera simmetrica di
fatto le performance di coppia sono più
alte che di quelle del singolo quindi
questo concetto funziona anche nel caso
di performance molto diverse e la fatica
che si mette nel fare il Task viene
bilanciato tra i due
potete immaginare che lo step successivo
a questo punto finora ho parlato solo di
esperimenti di laboratorio è quello di
andare nella vita reale Quindi di
provare se questo concetto funziona
anche nei Task che vi ho descritto prima
questo sono gli esperimenti che stiamo
facendo in questi mesi in cui abbiamo
nei due ambiti che identificata
all'inizio nell'ambito della scrittura e
nell'ambito dell'apprendimento di Come
suonare uno strumento molto complesso
che il violino possiamo utilizzare dei
meccanismi di connessione appunto
tramite robot per facilitare
l'apprendimento questi sono studi che
stiamo facendo in questi mesi i
risultati sembrano promettenti ma da
persona che fa ricerca purtroppo ancora
non posso dire se funzionerà veramente
oppure no perché abbiamo altri quattro
mesi fino alla fine di questo progetto
quello che posso dire è che questo è il
primo esempio di
questo concetto di mettere in
comunicazione le persone in
comunicazione fisica le persone tramite
robot viene portato fuori dall'ambito di
laboratorio in un scenario di
applicazione reale della vita di tutti i
giorni l'altra cosa che ci tengo a
sottolineare che non è un lavoro ha
detto prima un progetto europeo che
coinvolge molti partner non è un lavoro
solo mio o del mio gruppo ma un lavoro
di squadra la parte della scrittura
coinvolge anche in Pilar College di
Londra oltre che gli universitari
Newcastle e il Campus Biomedico di Roma
e il lavoro sui violinisti sul gli
studenti di violino coinvolge la scuola
superiore Sant'Anna Juve per la
progettazione dei robot È limpida al
college University Campus Biomedico per
la parte di esperimenti
concludo con
un messaggio finale anche per diciamo
non più che messaggio una
considerazione che voglio fare insieme a
voi perché sono sicuro che a qualcuno di
voi sentendo parlare di robotica nera
scienza intelligenza artificiale può
essere venuto il dubbio dei rischi
associati a queste tecnologie se ne
parla molto sui media si discute molto
se c'è un pericolo di un uso distorto di
queste tecnologie Tant'è che mi è
bastato fare una ricerca di un minuto su
Google che queste sono le tre prime
pagine che mi sono uscite Quindi da una
pagina un po' più discorsiva dell'INAIL
che chiede non è che i robot metteranno
a rischio il nostro lavoro nel futuro a
scenari più catastrofici per esempio di
Focus che dice i robot o quell'altra
pagina di i robot insieme
all'intelligenza artificiale sono il
rischio per l'estinzione umano ok Quindi
questa è la riflessione che volevo fare
detto questo che c'è ovviamente una
grossa attenzione sui possibili rischi
volevo così ricordare che la maggior
parte delle persone che si occupano di
robotica e neuroscienze da un lato
cercano di utilizzare i robot per
studiare meglio i meccanismi cerebrali e
dall'altro una volta che apprendiamo
come funziona il cervello possiamo
progettare dei robot migliori che
possono aiutare le persone nella vita
reale sia nell'ambito che può vi ho
descritto prima Cioè nell'imparare un
nuovo compito sia in ambito per esempio
riabilitativo abbiamo delle tecnologie
che servono per aiutare a valutare e a
fare terapia di vari tipi di malattie
come per esempio il Parkinson quindi
l'ultimo messaggio è che
sicuramente a qualsiasi
scoperta scientifica o innovazione
tecnologica corrispondono Certamente dei
rischi questo è sempre così e sempre
stato così quello che possiamo fare Non
solo noi come ricercatori Ma tutta la
società è quello di informarsi vigilare
e soprattutto far la giusta pressione su
Chi decide quindi sui decisori politici
politici affinché le ricerche e le
tecnologie vengono utilizzati per la
crescita dell'umanità e non permetterla
a rischio Grazie
[Applauso]